mana from your bio I believe it says
you've started a non-profit so these
films that you say to connect people's
heart to the earth I think more of what
you were talking about before I started
in the process of making the film I
wanted to do it to educate people and to
give back and so I created a company
called global wholeness it actually
started as global healing and then we
changed the name because I know you know
if we put it out there global healing
and we're perpetually healing or Never
whole so I changed the name to global
wholeness and we already are hole is
just remembering that and walking into
it and in six weeks i had IRS approval
of my nonprofit status and everybody
said this is this unheard of and so I
said well there's another green lights
but we're meant to go out and do this
and so my goal is to create films that
uplift people and help them understand
that we are connected not just to each
other but as we share in the film we are
physiologically not just symbolically
but physiologically connected to the
earth and so as we create this
collective heart signal we have the
capacity to really impact what's going
on on earth itself and I believe that
that intention in the film also is why
we were mentioned at the United Nations
on international peace day on the 30th
anniversary of peace day one of my
followers was on a panel at the United
Nations about what can we do as
individuals okay in terms of creating
real and lasting peace in people's lives
in avon Madison who is one who is
instrumental in starting peace day 30
years ago so here's an example that
contributes to personal as well as
planetary peace so the United Nations
has heard about it we'll see what
happens next but I was very excited to
hear that my film was discussed on
international peace day 2112 is a hot
top
yeah and Hollywood seems to portray it
as the end of the world other people
feel it as a shift in consciousness and
and us being forced to change from maybe
more of a money-based thinking and into
the warm heart bae sinking what's your
take well I have been interested in
beyond 2012 because this is like a
bottle like everything is converging you
energy is so fast and you make a plan
and the only thing you can count on is
it's going to be different in our and
our energies coming back at us so fast
if you put fear-based thought thoughts
and feelings out there it's going to
come back and you'll get an opportunity
to experience it and it's it used to be
slower like if you were afraid of
something it might take a month or two
before you get a chance to really take a
look at it now it's hours days hours and
so I think that's what the 2012 is this
acceleration and then the opportunity to
really consciously decide how am I go
how am I going to be and how am I going
to think and act and feel through this
transformation beyond 2012 and the
solution is in in the connection in the
feeling and the heart based energy
between all of us and as I I talked
about in the film the law of confluence
and that's something that I developed
and it's sort of the next step beyond
the law of attraction which absolutely
works that's a profound operative law
but the law of compliments is the next
thing and that is feeling creates
connection love manifests abundance and
heart creates wholeness and so that is
that energy of three things converging
together it's no longer what I want out
there but how do I interact in my
environment to create peeling healing
and connection in peace
you